Дорогі семикласники,
вітаю вас на уроці української мови.
Звати мене Анастасія Євдокимова.
Сьогодні ми поговоримо про прислівник.
З цим нам допоможуть
наші добрі друзі коти.
Кожен з них і кожна з цих кицьок
братиме участь сьогодні
разом з нами у нашому уроці.
Почнемо ми з того, що пригадаємо –
які частини мови ми вже з вами вивчили.
Ми говорили про самостійні частини мови.
Незабаром поговоримо про службові.
З самостійних частин мови
ми пам’ятаємо про іменник,
який відповідає на
питання (хто?, що?),
про прикметник (який?, чий?),
займенник, числівник, дієслово.
Зрештою сьогодні ми починаємо
говорити про прислівник.
Що таке прислівник?
Прислівник – це самостійна незмінна частина мови.
Поки що ми на цьому зупинимось.
Давайте з’ясуємо – чому ж
ця частина мови є незмінною?
Досі у всіх тих частинах мови, які
ми вивчали, закінчення змінювалось.
Так, наприклад, ми відмінювали
іменник у родовому відмінку.
Наприклад, кіт
(кого? чого?) – кота,
або в знахідному, або в
давальному (кому?, чому?) – коту.
Чи в дієслова, коли змінювалось це закінчення.
У прислівника воно залишається сталим.
Прислівник відповідає на такі запитання:
чому?, з якою метою?,
звідки?, коли?, як? і багато інших.
Давайте розглянемо приклад.
Пошкодив лапу (чому?) ненароком.
Випадково наш котик йшов і пошкодив лапу.
Перекинув миску (з
якою метою?) навмисне.
Або навпаки ненавмисне
– він хотів напакостити.
Вистрибнув (звідки?) – він
вистрибнув звідкись з гори,
звідкись зверху, наприклад, з шафи.
Втік (коли?) позавчора.
Ми знаємо цей час і можемо
сказати вчора, позавчора або завтра.
Прибіг (як?) радісно,
з якою емоцією.
Отже, всі ці питання ми
детальніше розглянемо трішки далі.
Прислівник виражає ознаку дії,
ознаку стану, ознаку іншої ознаки
або вказує на обставини, за
яких відбувається дія чи явище.
Наприклад. Мурчав (як?) голосно.
Ознака дії – сила мурчання нашого котика.
Мурчав (якою мірою?)
надзвичайно голосно.
Тут йдеться про те, що (надзвичайно)
підсилює ознаку іншої ознаки.
Надзвичайно підсилює наше голосно.
Він не просто голосно мурчав,
він мурчав дуже голосно.
Тому ми ставимо це питання.
Або зустрілися (коли?, за яких обставин?,
коли відбувається дія?) опівночі.
Бо так само ми могли би з’ясовувати
інші деталі цієї зустрічі з нашим котом.
Тобто ознака дії, стану,
ознака іншої ознаки
чи обставина за яких відбувається дія –
це те, на що вказує наш прислівник.
Давайте спробуємо поєднати
пари у відповідних словосполученнях.
Знайдемо необхідні
нам прислівники ліворуч.
Отже, у нас є: стежка, котлета,
дивитися, говорити, доглядати.
Різні частини мови. А
так само прислівники:
лагідно, навпростець,
дбайливо, по-київськи, сердито.
Стежка (куди вона
тягнеться?, як вона тягнеться?) –
вона тягнеться навпростець.
Котлета приготована за
певним рецептом (як?).
Котлета приготована по-київськи.
Так само, як ми знаємо
каву по-віденські, наприклад.
Дивитися сердито. Дивитися (як?)
сердито. Дивитися (як?) насуплено.
Це те, як ми реагуємо, наприклад,
на нашого кота на екрані.
Говорити або дбайливо, або лагідно.
Очевидно, що говорити лагідно,
а доглядати (як?) дбайливо.
Отже, всі ці нюанси – ми їх відчуваємо,
тому що ми користуємось мовою постійно.
Ми постійно використовуємо
різні її ресурси.
Коли ми розглянемо наступний слайд,
то ми з’ясуємо для себе, що з
усіма цими мовними прикладами
ми зустрічаємось щодня, якщо не щомиті.
Отже, прислівники можуть означати.
Стан природи: (як там?)
сонячно, морозно, темно, вітряно,
хороша погода, погана погода.
Ми її можемо неодмінно
охарактеризувати саме прислівниками.
Або стан людини: (як нам?)
соромно, боляче, приємно.
Або стан нашого кота, йому так само
може бути соромно, боляче чи приємно.
Потреби чи ставлення:
необхідно, потрібно, можна, варто.
Це теж те, що можна
застосувати і до нашого кота,
якому треба корм, якому необхідно поїсти.
Так само, як і нам з вами.
Чим же виступають прислівники в реченні?
А ми з вами пам’ятаємо, що бувають
головні члени речення і другорядні.
До головних належать підмет і присудок,
які відповідають на питання (хто?, що?)
і (що робити?, що зробити?) відповідно.
Так само другорядні члени речення
– означення, обставина і додаток.
Отже, прислівники у реченні бувають:
обставинами, означеннями
та, власне, присудками.
Розглянемо конкретні приклади і зрозуміємо,
що, насправді, це зовсім нескладно.
Перше речення. Улюблене
крісло кота стоїть праворуч.
Внизу екрана ви бачите
і кота і його крісло.
Отже, (хто?, що?) крісло (що
робить?) стоїть, стоїть (де?) праворуч.
Тобто слово праворуч на прикладі
цього речення є обставиною.
Якщо ж ми розглянемо наступний приклад...
Крісло ліворуч манить кота.
Оце наше крісло з екрана.
Крісло (яке?), яке саме з
усіх крісел, які є в кімнаті?
Те крісло, яке ліворуч.
Тобто ліворуч – наш прислівник,
який виступає означенням.
В останньому ж прикладі:
самотньо в хаті - він є присудком,
адже це речення односкладне.
Пригадаймо, що односкладні речення –
це ті, в яких є лише
одна граматична основа –
або підмет, або присудок.
В нашому випадку –
присудок. Є самотньо в хаті.
Отже, наш прислівник може бути і
обставиною, і означенням, і прислівником.
Головне – знайти те головне
слово, від якого ми ставимо питання:
від присудка, від підмета.
І правильно поставити власне це запитання.
Адже саме від цього залежить
– яким буде це запитання
і що ж наш прислівник в конкретному
випадку, в конкретному реченні означає.
Адже завжди ми дивимось на контекст.
Так само прислівник
може бути вставним словом:
мабуть, можливо, напевно, безперечно.
Яке б із цих слів ми зараз не
підставили в наше речення – воно підійде.
Якщо кіт спокійно лежить,
то він, можливо, спить;
то він, мабуть, спить; то він, напевно,
спить; то він, безперечно, спить.
Не забуваємо, що вставні слова в реченнях
виділяються комами з обох
боків – на початку та в кінці.
Тепер переходимо до, начебто, непростих
табличок, але, насправді, дуже зрозумілих.
Ми з вами з’ясуємо, якими бувають
групи прислівників за значенням.
А бувають вони
означальними та обставинними.
В першій табличці розглянемо означальні.
Бачите – кіт на екрані теж
розглядає разом з нами.
Отже, вони бувають якісно-означальними.
Це – якісна характеристика дії чи
стану, коли ми можемо запитати (як?).
Як дати якісну характеристику?
Як нашому коту зараз?
Йому зараз радісно чи йому зараз
високо, коли він виліз на диван?
Далі – наступна категорія.
Це – кількісно-означальні.
Вони характеризують дію чи
ознаку з боку кількості та міри впливу.
Тобто скільки, яка кількість, як
багато, якою мірою, наскільки.
І можемо відповідати:
багато, мало або про кількість –
тричі, надзвичайно, трохи, зовсім трохи.
Далі наступна категорія – це спосіб дії.
Прислівники способу дії вказують
на те, яким способом, яким же чином,
відбувається та чи інша
дія, чи виявляється ознака.
Як? Яким способом?
Зненацька, навпочіпки, напам’ять, вголос.
Зверніть увагу, що слово напам’ять
може писатись разом і окремо
залежно від контексту, але до
цього ми повернемось пізніше.
Отже, такою є група прислівників
за означенням – означальні,
які відповідають на питання, ще раз:
(як?, скільки?, як багато?,
якою мірою?, як?, яким способом?)
Наступна група прислівників - обставинні.
Їх чотири цих категорії,
так само, як і обставин.
Пригадайте питання
обставин, які ви і так знаєте.
Отже, обставини місця, які
означають місце дії (де?, куди?, звідки?).
І тут ми вказуємо:
праворуч, вниз, вгорі, ліворуч.
Обставинні часу, які вказують
на час – коли відбувається дія:
(коли ж вона відбувається?,
відколи?, доки?, з якого часу?).
Торік, досі, зранку, завжди.
Обставинні причини – чому
відбувається ця дія, яка причина:
(чому?, через що?,
з якої причини?).
Спросоння, зопалу, ненароком.
Можуть бути різні причини.
І обставинні мети, які
вказують на мету конкретної дії:
(для чого?, з якою
метою?, навіщо?).
Навмисне, наперекір, напоказ.
Давайте розглянемо
ілюстрацію з нашим котом
і виконаємо завдання «Обережно, кіт».
Ми навчилися ставити запитання.
Тож перейдімо до практики.
Стрибати (скільки?). Скільки
може стрибати наш кіт?
Він може стрибати довго.
Спритний (якою мірою?). Дуже
спритний. Подивіться на його очі.
Вистрибнути (як?) - різко. Ми не
знали де він є і от він вистрибнув.
Кружляти навколо нас (скільки він може?).
Він може багато, дуже багато кружляти.
Заснути (коли?). Зранку. Всю ніч кіт
ходить по кухні і лише зранку засинає.
Тобто ми розуміємо, що на прикладі кота
ми можемо застосувати
прислівник до будь-якої ситуації.
Прислівники всі навколо нас.
Навіть коли ми вранці
прокидаємось і робимо руханку,
ми все одно використовуємо прислівники.
Адже і вгору, і вниз,
і праворуч, і ліворуч,
всі ці рухи і всі ці дії
– це все прислівники.
Отже, я хотіла би запропонувати вам
знайти відповідні прислівники
до вказаних значень слів.
Вказані значення слів ви бачите на дошці.
Давайте доберемо відповідні
прислівники до вказаних описів.
Дуже розсердившись.
Це як? Це – спересердя.
До недавнього часу. Де ж наш
відповідник? Донедавна, ось він.
До повного задоволення – донесхочу.
Робити доти, доки більше не захочеться.
Даремно, безрезультатно тобто марно.
Повністю тобто ущент, геть.
Ущент, щоб нічого не залишилось.
Як-небудь – абияк.
Зверніть увагу, що абияк пишеться разом і
про це ми поговоримо на наступних уроках.
Без зацікавлення – байдуже, коли
немає абсолютно ніякого інтересу.
Куди-небудь у невизначеному
напрямку. Це куди? Це – геть.
Охоче із задоволенням – залюбки.
Отже, нам не вистачає тут лише
кота, оскільки ми його давно не бачили.
Це наш кіт, якій готовий спересердя,
донедавна, донесхочу, марно,
ущент, абияк, байдуже, геть,
залюбки рухатись нашими слайдами
і рухатись темою прислівників,
як і рухаємось з вами ми.
Наступне завдання
пов’язане з фразеологізмами.
Всі ми їх любимо, всі ми їх знаємо.
Фразеологізми ви бачите на дошці.
Які значення має кожен з цих
фразеологізмів? Почнемо рухатись знизу.
Як кіт наплакав. Це скільки? Це – мало.
Жити на широку ногу. Це як?
Це – жити багато, жити так,
аби собі ні в чому не відмовляти.
Йти не своїми ногами.
Коли ноги підказують про те,
що вони вже втомились. Йти поволі.
Спати без задніх ніг.
Коли ви не відчуваєте ані ніг, ані рук,
ви провалюєтесь
повністю в сон. Міцно спати.
Не мати кінця-краю. Не бачити
цих меж. Це – нескінченно.
Коли ми дивимось на море – і воно нескінченне,
ми не бачимо іншого берега, правда.
Кинутись з усіх ніг. Швидко. Скільки
є сил, стільки і вкладати їх в цей біг.
Намокнути до останньої нитки.
Намокнути наскрізь, аби не
було жодної ділянки сухого одягу.
Так, коли неймовірна злива
влітку, тоді ми промокаємо повністю.
Як сніг на голову. Як падає
сніг на голову? Раптово.
Навіть коли ми його чекаємо, все
одно його поява для нас видається дивом.
Отже, прислівники є і
тут у фразеологізмах.
І, так, через фразеологізми,
ми можемо їх пояснити.
Тепер поговоримо про
ступені порівняння прислівників.
Зверніть увагу, що лише
якісно-означальні прислівники
можуть мати ступені
порівняння: вищий і найвищий.
Про ступінь порівняння
прикметників ми вже говорили.
Тут, насправді, те саме.
Розглянемо, наприклад, слово важливо.
Завдяки суфіксам -ш- та -іш-,
ми можемо утворити вищу форму:
важливіше або більш/менш важливо.
Так само, завдяки префіксу -най-,
ми можемо утворити найвищу форму:
найважливіше або найбільш/найменш важливо.
З словами: голосно, просто,
дотепно – буде те саме.
Адже
дотепно, дотепніше, більш/менш дотепно,
найдотепніше, найбільш/найменш дотепно.
Або просто, або голосно
– правило діє так само.
Але, зверніть увагу, що з: гарно,
багато і погано – трошки все інакше.
Тому що, якщо воно
гарне, то воно стає лише:
кращим і не гарнішим в жодному випадку.
Якщо його багато, то
його стає просто – більше.
Якщо погано, то стає – гірше.
Ці слова варто запам’ятати.
Отже, наш вищий ступінь може так
само підсилюватись такими словами як:
ще, трохи, значно, куди, далеко.
Не забуваємо про те, що
їх можна використовувати
для того, аби збагачувати нашу мову.
Під час утворення ступенів порівняння
відбуваються ті самі чергування,
що й у прикметників.
Так, випадають суфікси -к-, -ок-, -ек-.
Було швидко, стало – швидше.
Було широко (суфікс
-ок-), стало – ширше.
Було далеко (суфікс
-ек-), стало - дальше.
Так само відбувається чергування
приголосних: г, ж, з змінюється на жч.
Дорого – дорожче, низько –
нижче (-с- змінюється на -щ-).
Ми пам’ятаємо, що у фонетиці «щ»
позначає два звуки. Високо – вище.
Давайте складемо настанови
для нашого маленького котенятка
і утворимо ступені порівняння.
Перші кроки даються тяжко.
Як даються перші кроки? Найтяжче
– найвищий ступінь порівняння.
Доброму навчитися важко.
Доброму навчитися найважче
- найвищий ступінь порівняння.
Дешево від дірки з бублика.
Дешевше від дірки з бублика.
Адже дірка від бублика
це – нуль, це нічого.
Швидко сльоза висихає.
Ми з вами знаємо що
сльоза висихає найшвидше.
А збоку – найвидніше.
Порівняймо. Мурчик, який зображений
на фотографії стрибає найвище.
І якби наш Мурчик виліз на найвище
дерево. Чим відрізняються ці слова?
Передовсім тим, якими частинами мови
вони є та якими членами речення теж.
Адже Мурчик стрибає (як?)
найвище. Ось він наш прислівник.
Виліз на найвище дерево. Дерево
(яке?) найвище.
(Який? Яка? Яке?) це питання прикметників.
Відповідно «найвище» може бути
і прикметником, і прислівником.
Необхідно уважно читати
речення і зважати на контексти.
Давайте доберемо антоніми
до наших прислівників.
Всі ми їх знаємо і це буде
дуже просте для нас завдання.
Наш котик рухається вперед, а
може рухатись … (який антонім?)
правильно - назад.
Він може гуляти вдень,
а може гуляти ...вночі.
Він може прокидатись зранку, а
може виходити на полювання ...звечора.
Він нявчить іноді
голосно, а іноді ...тихо.
Нашому Мурчику може бути (як?)
може бути весело, а може бути ...сумно.
Коли наш Мурчик найактивніший?
Найактивніший він звісно влітку,
а найбільше він спить взимку.
Яку мову він розуміє? Він розуміє
по-нашому, а нявчить по-їхньому.
В обох випадках ми напишемо через дефіс.
Це правило ми вивчим трішки пізніше.
Нашому Мурчику може бути
добре, а може бути погано.
Він може рухатись швидко,
а може рухатися повільно.
Ця вправа нагадує нам
про те – що таке антоніми.
Антоніми – це слова
протилежні за значенням.
Тоді як синоніми навпаки – ті,
які є близькими за значеннями.
Ще одна вправа. Доберіть
із дужок необхідне слово
і складіть продовження розповіді,
використовуючи прислівники.
Це було (взимку, влітку, восени, навесні).
Оберіть ту пору року, яка вам
найбільше подобається і запишіть.
Якось (увечері, вдень, вранці,
вночі) у якій порі, як найкраще.
З вулиці долинув (дуже,
надзвичайно, трохи) дивний звук.
Ми розуміємо, що, насправді,
в нашій історії прийшов кіт.
Я (тихо, повільно, швидко, боязко, повагом –
(може бути дуже багатий
синонімічний ряд того, як ми рухались),
підійшов(ла) до вікна
й побачив(ла) там…
Що ж я там побачила чи
що у цьому вікні побачили ви?
Нехай це буде вашим домашнім завданням.
Допишіть цю історію про нашого котика,
і що ж він робив на вулиці, та
доберіть необхідні прислівники.
Підсумуємо!? Що
ми дізнались сьогодні.
Сьогодні ми говорили про прислівники.
А прислівник – це самостійна
незмінна частина мови.
Адже закінчення
прислівників не змінюються.
Яка відповідає на питання (як?, яким
способом?, якою мірою?) та багато інших.
Ми з вами з’ясували,
що в реченні прислівники можуть
бути і обставинами, і означеннями.
Усе залежить від того,
від якого головного члена речення ми
ставимо питання до нашого прислівника.
Групи прислівників за значенням
бувають обставинні і означальні.
Це ми теж з’ясували.
Коли ми говорили про
ступені порівняння прислівників,
то пригадували тему «Прикметник»,
утворюючи вищий і найвищий
ступінь: дорого-дорожче-найдорожче.
Не забуваємо про такий прислівник
як гарно, який стає – краще.
Я пропоную вам кілька завдань
для самостійного виконання –
аби ви перевірили себе.
Так, вони не прості, але
потребують вашої концентрації.
Завдання ви бачите на екрані.
Знайдіть у кожній парі слів прислівник
і виконайте це завдання правильно.
Я впевнена – вам це вдасться.
(Правильним є варіант Г).
Адже, в парі «швидкий і
швидкість» прислівника немає зовсім,
на відміну від радісно, далеко,
вдень, які наявні у інших парах.
Наступне завдання. У якому рядку
прислівник вжито неправильно?
Підказка - йдеться про ступені
порівняння вищий і найвищий,
які ми з вами розглядали сьогодні.
Завдання ви бачите на екрані.
Правильна відповідь,
якщо ви розглянете уважно,
(це, звісно, варіант:
В) більш точніше.
Адже такої форми не існує.
Точніше, більш точно або менш точно,
найбільш точно або найменш точно,
але більш точніше – це неправильно.
Ще одне завдання, воно мабуть найскладніше
і найбільше потребує вашої уваги.
У рядках Максима Рильського
«Світ по-новому відкривати,
поете, обов’язок твій».
«По-новому» – наш прислівник,
нам потрібно з’ясувати – яким
членом речення він виступає.
Давайте проаналізуємо.
Почнемо з того, що знайдемо
головні члени речення.
«Світ» (хто?, що?) – підмет, (що
робити?) «відкривати» – присудок.
Отже, ми з’ясували, що наш
прислівник не є підметом і не є присудком.
Відповідно варіанти В і
Г ми відкинули відразу.
«Світ відкривати»
(як?) «по-новому».
Тож запитання (як?) підказує
нам, що йдеться про обставину,
ми підкреслюємо її штрих пунктиром.
Чую пролунав дзвінок, тож
пора завершувати наш урок.
Дякую вам, дорогі семикласники,
Бажаю вам успіхів під час
вивчення теми «Прислівник».
Ідіть відпочивайте.